bueno la razón que se creó oficial por
la cual la y corea del norte entera y
rechazó estas vacunas es que no querían
ningún tipo de técnico de personal
entrar al país para asesorar la creación
de estas cadenas de frío necesarias para
las vacunas hay que recordar que condena
el sur ha estado completamente cerrada
al mundo exterior desde que comenzó la
pandemia en 2020 otra razón posiblemente
adicional es que corea del norte no
quiere depender de ningún país externo
en el tema de vacunas en qué situación
queda esto cuál es la posibilidad de que
corea del norte acepte ayudas y qué tipo
de ayudas pues por poner un ejemplo
corea del sur que ha prometido ya dar
todas las ayudas necesarias
para el país vecino ha tratado de
comunicarse hoy con corea del norte y no
ha recibido por el momento respuesta
alguna por otra parte
del norte ha alabado el sistema chino de
kobe 0 y algunas fuentes informativas
han hablado de que ha habido contactos
diplomáticos con china para recibir
algún tipo de ayuda humanitaria pero
muchos expertos
subrayan en este caso que es muy poco
probable que lo que corea del norte vaya
a solicitar sean vacunas porque de nuevo
no quiere dejar entrar a nadie en el
país para asesorar esa distribución esa
correcta distribución de vacunas y otro
de los motivos sería no dejar entrar
precisamente a las personas porque el
régimen norcoreano ha reforzado mucho su
control sobre la población en ese
sentido la pandemia le ha venido muy
bien tal y como denuncian las
organizaciones de derechos humanos